Germany was shocked,
but everyone falls in love with the AfD.
You can't stop that,
can you?
Well,
so everyone maybe not quite yet,
but it's actually so uh.
It is currently
the ground is preparing for an alternative for Germany,
who can also move into government.
We have seen it quite clearly now um
in Sonneberg with a Robert armchairman
and also in ragon yesnitz,
where we now also provide a mayor,
so the 1st district administrator,
the 1st mayor,
speak,
this is 1 sign.
We have made it the 1st time
actually achieve a majority of the votes.
In the population,
although all other parties have stood together
and appealed does not elect the AfD representative,
but that shows
in Thuringia
at least people are already ready,
that they say, moment,
I won't be patronized anymore.
Here in this country so much goes wrong
and I no longer do what the media tells me,
what the other parties tell Me,
who, of course,
never want to give up their pounds.
I'm glad.
We are now entering a phase,
where we can really participate
and I think that will go on
in state elections in the east,
in the state election in Bavaria
hopefully we will already see the strong gain
but in Bavaria it is of course a little more difficult
with the CSU and the free voters,
both of them
as the better alternative
want to sell for Germany,
where the original is the AfD are conservatives.
We then,
we want to preserve Germany,
that in the eighties we
nineties knew and loved.
And this Germany needs your future,
it needs the AfD
and I'm really looking forward to the upswing,
which, hopefully,
will continue to lie ahead of us now.